knock knock who's there space bugs
[Music]
don't ask me what that was we're moving
on i'm not gonna dwell on it
hey take two doctor who review we have
arrived at
knock knock which is our first pretty
much
entirely contemporary set episode most
of the pilot was contemporary but we
still had some jumping around in time
and space we had see daleks and
mavellans for some reason the show had
to remind us that those were a thing
that existed
i don't know why but here we have a an
episode
entirely set modern day earth focusing
on
bill other people her age the doctor's
there it's effectively a bit of a
haunted house thing and it's also
i would say the first not all that great
episode of series 10.
it's not awful it doesn't completely
fall apart but it doesn't have the
elements that are bolstering and buoying
the other things that have gone on up to
this point i've had some pretty nice
things to say about the pilot about
smile about thin ice
and while i don't think any of those are
necessarily perfect episodes there was
definitely things going on in each of
them that bolstered what otherwise might
have been
a decent episode into something
genuinely good
this doesn't quite have it i mean part
of it might just be that it's
bringing in elements that i'm just it's
not what i come to doctor who for
it's kind of the closest that series 10
gets to
the at-home domestics which is something
that
was introduced in the davies era and i
didn't like about
those stories with rose whenever her
family came in and
really care all that much for martha's
family
when they came in and like i'll give a
pass to donna's family because i love
wolf so much but like her mom annoyed me
and while this isn't quite at that level
um and let also to be clear like moffat
continued this
sort of thing into his era i don't want
it to seem like only davies did this
but at this point this is far from the
most egregious but it does have that
same feel the same like
oh here's people who like we wouldn't
involve in this
otherwise and since they don't live in
weird space places would never expect to
encounter any of this
and like i do why why and i get part of
it is the vibe that it's going for it
gives it that
and then there were none kind of eye
because basically when the
when the rest of the housemates get
introduced to bill my first thought is
fodder fodder fodder fodder fodder i'm
looking at them like the cast of uh
of a teen slasher horror movie i'm like
oh you're all gonna die
and they pretty much all do except then
they don't
i'll come back to that but the overall
vibe of the thing
and also i think the thing is the
dynamic between bill and the doctor
feels off here
and not in a they're poorly written or
out of character
kind of way but more in a this situation
brings out something that doesn't jive
with their dynamic and i get
why it's being done i'm not necessarily
going to argue with it from a
narrative or character development
standpoint because it makes it clear
that bill
as much fun as she is having with the
doctor does not
want what he's doing to touch every
aspect of her life she doesn't want
traveling with him to be
her life she wants things that will just
be hers
that's why she keeps trying to hustle
him out of the house although i
really don't understand why she does the
oh he's my granddad
thing like i i legitimately don't i feel
like it was just there for the
awkwardness of it
but as someone who doesn't enjoy
awkwardness or cringe-style humor it
does absolutely nothing for me and i
don't know why it's even
present it contributes nothing to the
story or the entire interactions or
anything else
but even though i appreciate that it is
establishing that bill
wants some boundaries and she doesn't
want the doctor there all the time
which is actually an important contract
especially coming off of clara
who you know despite her relationship
with danny and everything else made it
very clear that like she
kind of wanted to be doing stuff with
the doctor forever like if danny had
ever said yes i'll travel with you and
the doctor as well she basically would
have lived in the tardis and that's very
clear
here this gives us another feeling of
like okay bill
that is not what's going on she loves
this but she wants stuff that's just for
her and
she had thought that this new house with
these new people would be that and
here's the doctors what what are you
doing dude so again i get it and there's
validity to doing that but it's just not
as dynamic or as fun
as other episodes between the two of
them have been up to this point
i mean the other characters are really
all pretty much fodder there isn't a lot
to
any of them and it's hard to feel much
when any of them
die i suppose i do want to address i
guess paul
the one who was crushing on bill a
little bit
um so here's the thing i don't have a
problem with the character and i
actually think for
what those interactions are doing it
does it pretty well but it does sort of
make me frustrated that for things that
it illustrates
but i also know because that's not the
point it's not gonna have the time to
really get
into so especially re-watching it now
and
keeping an eye on this more carefully
she really does
yo for as much as she was accused of
basically walking around going
hi i'm bill and i like girls all the
time she
really does avoid talking to him and
bringing up the fact that she prefers
women until it's clear she really needs
to
so and that's very accurate
i mean if you if you've ever been
pursued by someone
that like you're not feeling
most of us don't really
want to shoot them down and we're kind
of hoping that maybe if we just don't
reciprocate at all they'll back off but
generally they
oftentimes they don't and then you have
to kind of draw the line now where i get
a little bit
is his reaction once he finds out that
she prefers girls is this big
thing of relief was like oh well i never
even had a shot and part of me is like
okay yeah that's accurate but another
part of me is like
so if she had been straight you just
would have
sulked and whined forever as if you
deserved a shot
because that's what it feels like it's
implying again i i don't have a problem
with that
being there and it does feel
representative of stuff that does happen
but it doesn't annoy me a little bit
that it it kind of brings that up but it
doesn't have time to
do anything with that it's just kind of
there oh you know i said
that the doctrine bill dynamic is a
little bit wonky for me that's actually
not until they get to the house
initially when he's helping her move
there's actually some things about their
interactions that i really like
and she starts asking more questions
because you know he drops a thing like
you know saying that he's a timeline
he's like time what's that your job
and again asking the questions that he's
not used to being asked or at least not
used to having them murdered this way
and he offhandedly mentions regeneration
and
regeneration what's that and you know
he's realizing he's
leading her onto information that he's
not comfortable talking about yet
so that again that sort of push-pull of
her
prodding every time she every time he
does or says something where she's like
what
hang on i'm not going to let that pass
let's examine that for a minute and i
love that she does that but again once
they get to the house that
element is kind of gone i don't know
whether or not this episode is meant to
be genuinely creepy or not
i feel like it is it doesn't it
is framed and shot and presented in such
a way that i'm not
getting a hint of irony or camp to it so
i think it's meant to be sincere
but there isn't an awful lot of tension
in this for me um for a couple of
reasons the first is
especially given how large this cast is
like i know they're all they're probably
all going to die because you wouldn't
have this many of them for them all to
live although they do all of you again
i'll come back to that
but like to compare it with something
else that had a similar mood something
like say
hide where there's only two other people
there and you get to know them
pretty well you do actually get scared
for them because you have some
investment
in them and with so few of them they
don't feel disposable but with a cast
this big i can't get invested in any of
these people so when they start getting
picked off i'm just like
yeah okay figure that would happen and
then in addition to that
the landlord is like well you know that
he's the
thing going on behind i mean like
outer space wood lice okay i didn't call
that but obviously he's at the heart of
it and that's clear from the beginning
so there isn't really even a sense of
mystery about it as to ooh what are we
dealing with like well we're dealing
with a skeevy landlord
who is clearly dangerous we just don't
know in what way
i think i feel like that's something
that uh well it's
i was gonna say doctor who but honestly
lots of shows uh and movies even
have a tendency to do which is to tip
their hand in terms of
uh it being too easy to identify
what is the problem either firmly
identifying an object or a person
or whatever like okay so it's clearly
them but
the only mystery as well but how and i'm
like i i
to me there's a lot more tension i'm
wondering what is even causing any of
this
as opposed to knowing what's causing it
just going i don't know how but i know
it's that guy
you know that doesn't engage me as much
so the way it's it's
all put together just doesn't really
latch in for me all that well
and the bugs the thing is i should be
more creeped out by this because i don't
like bugs
it's not it's not bad enough to like
call it a phobia but like
i do kind of have that going on so this
should have been skeevier
to me than it is i don't know if part of
it is the limitations of the budget and
the effects
because they don't look bad but they do
look fake so maybe that's kind of it
it's not
it's not clicking the uh reaction to me
because of
how not like real bugs uh crawling on
people it actually looks
i don't know maybe you know when it
comes to the housemates i think the one
good bit that resulted in a nice line
that i liked
was when um the doctor tells one of them
you know don't be scared he goes why
it doesn't help um and that's actually
kind of an interesting contrast
especially given his
fear is a superpower speech that he gave
in
uh listen but again that was to a child
who he was trying to reassure
this is now maybe adult is pushing it
but this is a grown person like i can't
deal with you being scared and panicky
right now
that he is so i i like that the doctor
this doctor especially especially
knowing how socially awkward he began
he distinguishes that he has to treat
kids
different from how he treats grown-ups
and
maybe i'm putting more weight on that
than there should be but i like it
so let's talk about the villain the
landlord
and that's sort of the one way in which
this sort of ties into
the uh social and capitalistic aspects
that have been recurring
across this series and last episode we
had sutcliffe
who was just flat out letting people get
eaten so that he could
basically make fuel and here we have a
landlord now
it's a bit more tangential yes the
villain is a landlord but that's
something that he is
the nature of what it means to be a
landlord isn't
really at the heart of of his villainy
and you know what it is that makes him
dangerous
if it was a case of so
i'm not saying this is what they should
have done but this would have tied in
more thematically
so at the end we meet who is initially
presented as
his daughter turns out it's his mother
this wooden woman
who is being kept alive by the bugs
and the bugs need to feed and that's
ultimately his motivation for why he's
doing what he's doing
now that doesn't tie into sort of the
predatory nature
of landlordship i mean it
it just doesn't and what might have
worked better to play into that
theme would have been if say for lack of
a better way to a
better way to put it if his mother
hadn't said like been absorbed
into the house but he could still hear
her and communicate with her and what
was sustaining that was the bugs
and so that he was literally letting his
tenants die to prop up
the thing that he owned and how it gave
him what he wanted
and i guess in a way it's kind of doing
that but the show doesn't really
properly tie
the house to her until after she dies
and
the thing starts falling apart in
basically what feels like a video game
kind of find out oh you killed the final
boss and now escape before the
before the castle explodes or whatever
but i'm not necessarily saying that the
show should have done that i'm not sure
that would have actually
resulted in a better episode i'm just
saying that would have tied into the
thematics a bit more of what's been
going on
in this series so far and some of the
stuff that's going to come later
whereas the fact that it doesn't do that
makes this one of the weaker tie-ins
to themes that have gotten established
and i know will continue to
crop up as we move forward that said
he's got one great line i'm like oh
oh that feels like a good proper dig
which is you know they i think it's bill
says you know but they won't come for
you referring to the bugs and he goes
i'm the exception i'm the landlord
i.e the things i'm going to request of
you
i'm going to expect from you you don't
get to expect that from me i have
different
rules that i operate by and
you know it's it's hard this series
given a lot of the
thematic underpinnings to not go on uh
politically
driven tangents i mean they're
they're not unconnected because these
themes are in here but i don't want to
go off
on too extended a thing on things like
landlords and
uh capitalism why not but like i'm going
to address it it's going to happen
it's in the episodes so and and i really
did
dig the heck out of that the whole wrap
up
and the real the realization that
it is his mother not his daughter
is interesting to a
point here's where i get a little bit
iffy on it especially on paper like let
me be clear the performances
actually do a bit to sell this probably
better than i would have bought it
otherwise although i'm still a little
because the performances from the
landlord from his mother from bill from
the doctor
in that climactic scene are all really
good and they do a good job of selling
what needs to be sold
but i still don't know if i want what
they're selling and what i mean by that
in terms of specifically
i buy i certainly buy
a child prioritizing their
parent so much that they will do
horrible things to save their parent
i buy that that was part of what made
the empty child so freaking terrifying
back in series one
the fact that yeah a child would cause
all this damage if they thought it would
save their mother
but the problem is he's an adult now and
more than that he's an adult who's
a little off-putting but more or less
seems to know how to function in society
they pull a little bit of an arrested
development thing with him at the very
end but it doesn't feel properly earned
it doesn't
feel like this is
how he always is it feels like this is
how we're going to have him act at the
very end
to sell the emotion of it a bit more so
it's not
quite coming together on that front
with with the whole like because like i
said
we we've seen him he he appears to be a
functioning if
slightly off-putting adult and now all
of a sudden
the only way his motivation makes sense
to do for 70 years if is if he is
basically
almost entirely an arrested child who
has never
grown up in any way shape or form and is
still that dependent on a parent
and i guess i just i think maybe part of
the problem is
i feel like way too much media latches
on to this
idea of childhood
trauma really permanently forever
screwing up someone in a way that they
will never recover from and most won't
even try
look childhood trauma it's especially
something like the loss of a parent it's
not something i had to go through so i
can't speak to that
but you know everybody has things that
screw them
up as a kid like everybody i don't care
how perfect your parents are
something about the the place where you
lived the house you lived in
your parents something about it did
something that
if you could go back you'd probably undo
it resulted in a non-ideal
uh aspect of who you are but
to extrapolate that as far as this does
it feels
well honestly it feels like a serial
killer cliche
you know something happened in his
childhood and now he kills people
again i'm not going to say never that
something like that happens but i feel
like it's overused
and maybe that's the other thing maybe
i'm just sick of that as a justification
for
why someone who is who either kills
people or who is willing to let people
die does what they do
oh well it goes back to his mother
like not everything has to be freudian
you know
i think that'll about wrap it up oh no i
said it was going to come back to the
everybody lives thing
i don't know why they did that either
like these people weren't interesting
enough for me to be invested
in them being saved so
i don't know why they just do i mean i
suppose it's less traumatic for bill
that way
and it's cleaner it results in fewer
questions a fewer loose ends and there
would be the you know there'd be a
police inquiry and all these things so
like
i guess it ties that up but like for the
purposes of this story
i don't care oh they're all safe
okay whatever knock knock you re-watched
it lately what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
and i have a patreon which is what
enables me to pay my bills and keeps the
lights on around here plus i've got
other things besides
hitting the like subscribe and sharing
the surround will also help me out
because yeah i these things aren't
showing up for as many people as they
used to
uh i've got analytics to bear that out
but even if you're
not able to do that it's okay no
pressure i'm not going to tell you what
to do because end of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you